[Musique]
avec volée une frappe bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à une de la
presse pour commencer la campagne de
l'entre-deux-tours enfance on en parlait
à l'instant avec damien ok on commence
par la déclaration des manuels macron
sur sa réforme des retraites dont il se
dit prêt dorénavant à je cite discuter
cet appel du pied en direction de la
gauche est perçue par l'opinion comme un
repli tactique du président sortant
accusé de se livrer à une acrobatie
électoraliste pour capter les électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon d'où le dessin de
kaka à la une qui le montre exécutant
une pirouette sur la lettre fille le
symbole des insoumis un signal politique
préoccupant selon le journal qui
s'inquiète de ce que ce recul sur le
recul de l'âge de la retraite puisse
être le premier renoncement à ce qui
fonde ce qui fonderait la crédibilité du
programme d' emmanuel macron maquereau à
la gauche si tu reviens j'annule rien
dans une allusion narquoise au célèbre
message de 2008 prêtés à nicolas sarkozy
qui a d'ailleurs annoncé hier son
ralliement à emmanuel macron libération
exprime son scepticisme face à la volte
face du président qui essaie de montrer
un visage un peu différent mais préfère
les paroles à des gages concrets
de son côté marine le pen la candidate
d'extrême droite a présenté son
programme pour faire face je cite à une
crise démocratique qu'elle présente
comme sans précédent notamment en
généralisant le recours au référendum et
en contournant à la fois le parlement et
le conseil constitutionnel en disant
vouloir revivifier les institutions et
le fonctionnement démocratique
la patronne du arènes chercheur est en
réalité à piétiner l'état de droit
d'après l'humanité qui accuse une
nouvelle fois l'extrême droite d'avancer
masqué
cette critique est relayée également
dans une tribune publiée par le monde ou
quatre professeurs de droit public met
en garde contre la proposition de marine
le pen de recourir au référendum
notamment pour imposer le principe de
priorité nationale
un projet qui revient selon eux à violer
la constitution et attaquer là encore
l'état de droit comme l'ont fait
ailleurs en europe les dirigeants
hongrois et polonais le droit
constitutionnel selon marine le pen est
et reste il libéral prévient-il la
presse française hélène qui s'interroge
aussi ce matin sur le salaire du patron
de ce thé lantiss qui atteint de tels
niveaux que l'un des actionnaires
minoritaires du groupe automobile
souhaite le contester lors d'une
assemblée générale qui se tient
aujourd'hui un salaire de 2 millions
d'euros auxquels s'ajoute un montant
variable de 7 millions et demi d'euros
la rémunération de carlos tavares
interpelle le quotidien la croix qui
reconnaît que le groupe issu de la
fusion psa fiat chrysler sort certes
d'une année exceptionnelle avec 13
milliards d'euros de bénéfices mais se
demande si cela justifie les sommes
astronomiques je cite en passe d'être
attribuées aux patrons de ces lentilles
ce qui pourrait se voir octroyer
également pauline 30,2 millions d'euros
sous forme d'actions et 25 millions sur
son compte un montant global équivalent
à 3300 années de smic selon la croix qui
évoque une logique de la goinfrerie sur
laquelle la campagne pour la
présidentielle ne peut pas faire
l'impasse s'il faut se saisir de ce
sujet ce n'est pas par démagogie ou pour
céder à la pente facile des discours
anti élites au contraire dans la période
actuelle je cite il ne faudrait pas que
l'indécence de quelques uns se
transforme en carburant du populisme la
voie de la croix hélène à la une
également ce matin la visite du
président biélorusse loukachenko à
vladimir poutine au menu de cette
rencontre l'alliance entre les deux pays
et bien sûr la guerre en ukraine lors
d'une conférence de presse au cosmodôme
vost nochi vostotchny c'est sa reprise
ce matin par le quotidien russe
kommersant le président russe a martelé
que le néonazisme jeu le site était
devenu un fait réel en ukraine que la
guerre était inévitable et que ce qui
fait la russie c'est aider les gens à se
libérer je le cite toujours dans le
journal d'après le journal suisse le
temps cette propagande du kremlin est
sous tendue par les discours d'extrême
droite de nationalistes qui trouve un
écho réel auprès de la population russe
à ces domaines que l'écrivain dmitri
gloukhovski explique par le fait que la
vérité sur la guerre est éradiqué de
toutes les manières possibles en russie
critique de cette guerre en ukraine le
posant au kremlin et ancien journaliste
proche de boris nemtsov qui a été
assassiné devant le kremlin en 2015
ademir car amour tu ça a été arrêté
devant son domicile lundi est condamné à
15 jours de prison pour insoumission aux
forces de l'ordre d'après le washington
post cette arrestation est intervenue
quelques heures seulement après que
l'opposant avait déclaré que le
gouvernement de vladimir poutine n'est
pas simplement corrompu pas simplement
kleptocratique pas seulement autoritaire
mais qu'il était je le cite un régime
d'assassins un mot pour terminer hélène
de la sanction historiques inédites dont
vient d'écoper le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson pour avoir
enfreint des règles anti qu'ovide qu'il
avait lui-même
ce nouveau rebondissement du pathé guèye
tu fais bien sûr la une de tous les
quotidiens outre manche le daily mirror
ne décolère pas on est dirigé par des
menteurs et des délinquants s'étrangle
le tabloïd qui précise pauline que richy
sounac le ministre des finances de boris
johnson et son épouse vont peut aussi
recevoir une amende johnson devient le
premier premier ministre en fonction à
enfreindre la loi titre line dependence
avec cette une qui ressemble à une
couverture du roman de bordeu d'agatha
christie le 10 downing street à 100 de
crime a party game party games dans le
dessein de mothern moerlen pour des
tiles bozzo sa femme et le chancelier de
l'échiquier joua devine qui je suis
tous les trois leurs contraventions
collée sur le front suis-je le premier
ministre demande des jeunes salut merci
beaucoup et rennes c'était la revue de
presse à tout à l'heure